[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Tuesday June 6th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
Apple kicked off its week-long worldwide
developers conference known as WWDC on
Monday the Highlight was the
introduction of a new augmented reality
headset The Vision Pro
CEO Tim Cook said the product had been
years in the making I believe that
augmented reality is a profound
technology
blending digital content with the real
world can unlock experiences like
nothing we've ever seen
so today I'm excited to announce an
entirely new AR platform with a
revolutionary new product we discussed
Apple's headset plans on the show before
it's a device that breaks a lot of the
company's traditional rules for new
launches but it stayed View at the
developers conference follows a script
Apple has used before getting app makers
on board with me to discuss this is
wsj's personal Tech news editor Shara
tipkin so Shara let's start with his big
news about the Apple headset The Vision
Pro can you just describe it a bit for
us it basically looks like ski goggles
that sits on top of your eyes the glass
that goes in front of your eyes can
either be clear so people around you can
see your eyes or it's kind of fogged so
you're a little more isolated from the
outside world and it has a strap around
the back of the head so basically it
looks like very Sleek very fancy ski
goggles that then let you see images on
top of the real world so maybe it's
watching a movie or having a FaceTime
call with your colleagues or watching
videos of your children how you use it I
mean other than putting it on your head
if I want to use one of the apps in the
headset do I need anything else you
basically are accessing all of your apps
right there in the headset so things
that Apple showed was FaceTime so you
could have a FaceTime call with your
colleagues and they would appear life
size in your room you could shoot 3D
video of your kids and basically kind of
relive that moment if you have a
panoramic photo it will be huge and kind
of immersive and you'll feel like you're
back in that place like you're in the
mountains again or whatever it is you
can use this for work you can use this
personally you can game with it Apple's
basically showing that anything that you
would do with your other devices you can
do with this one product on top of your
face you don't need another screen but
if you have your other screens they can
also work alongside it so your Mac or
your iPhone or whatever other Apple
products you use one of the things that
stood out to me watching this was that
you didn't need controllers or anything
in your hands to move around the space
to open up a new app how big of a game
changer is that that has actually been a
really hard thing to solve specifically
in virtual reality which is kind of
awareness of the person who's actually
using that product so what apple is
doing is basically your eyes are the
controllers so when you look at
something it will open that app or if
you navigate to a search bar you can
then use your fingers to select it so
it's using a combination of your eyes
and your hands and also your voice to
control this device so Apple has this
new chip inside the Vision Pro that is
basically just sensing everything in the
environment so that's kind of the way
that they're approaching this so you
don't need any weird controllers that
you have to learn how to hold correctly
and use it's really just yourself and
they said the effect is it almost feels
like it's reading your mind because
where you're looking is what it's
responding to okay the the next stage of
technology I suppose if somebody wants
one of these headsets when and where can
they get it it's going to be not cheap
so this will be about 3 500 it's going
to be available early next year in some
markets including the US so really Apple
introduced this right now at WWDC
because it wants developers to start
making apps for it so when this goes on
sale they want a full catalog of things
that we'll be able to do so it's not
just Apple's own products on there
that's kind of why they're giving this
kind of big lead time between when they
announce it and when it actually goes on
sale how Jordan is at for Apple getting
these other developers excited about the
heck it's really important if you've
looked at the iPhone's trajectory all of
its success really came because Apple
introduced an app store when the iPhone
first came out I don't think a lot of
people remember there wasn't actually an
App Store so it was really Limited in
terms of what you could do on the iPhone
now you know there's thousands and
thousands and thousands of apps that you
can choose from and that's really kind
of what has made the iPhone this really
popular Rich experience you know just a
few days ago meta announced to be was
bringing out an updated version of its
VR headset so tell us what is Apple's
competition in this space like one thing
that Apple kind of has going for it is
it waits a while to get into some
markets and what it comes out with is
usually kind of a very polished finished
product I think we'll probably see
Apple's competitors react to this you
know in their future products as well
figure out what they're going to change
it's really notable that Apple decided
to do
augmented reality as its first Focus you
know a lot of times we've really seen
virtual reality and gaming kind of be
the big thing that people really push
gaming is a part of this but it's not
the only part of this it's communication
It's Entertainment it's work it's home
Apple kind of divided its presentation
among these kind of different areas so
you know it's trying to kind of be the
everything device and what it sees is
the future of computing ishara Disney is
partnering with Apple to supply content
for this new platform rather than
working with another tech company or
even trying to develop something
themselves but Disney and apple are
competitors in the streaming space and
Disney is partnering with them anyway so
what does this tell us apple and Disney
are competitors but they've also been
very close as two companies Steve Jobs
invested in Disney the two companies
have long been close and the reality is
yes they compete in streaming but Disney
needs to be in front of customers
wherever they are and lots of people
have iPhones lots of people have iPads
so even though they may be competing in
terms of streaming they also have to
partner in other areas and it's really
important for both of those companies to
have the content and to have the devices
and be where customers want them to be
alright let's talk about some
non-headset related news out of WWDC
what else was announced on Monday you
know along with like the head said Apple
had some interesting features for iOS 17
like live voicemail transcriptions you
can finally set multiple timers they
showed off with the iPad which is
something that's been lacking for a long
time you can send sort of live updates
of where you are so people in the
messages app will be able to see if
you're home if you are trying to call
someone on FaceTime and they don't
answer you can leave a message so you
know there's a bunch of new features
that are things that we are all going to
be using this fall basically the new
headset is something that is probably
Out Of Reach for most people to buy
right away so it's some of these other
little features that maybe you know may
not be as kind of gee whiz as the
headset but are things that are actually
going to be more applicable to our lives
alright that was our personal Tech news
editor Shara tipkin
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]